what we went out for a little supposed
to be a life for you mile ride we're at
the back of the pack after making some
adjustments there's not much service up
here one wrong turn and your GPS battery
phone dies you get seriously lost
we almost got turned around a bunch of
times but we ended up figuring you know
I was with Adam we were kind of like
together on the school finisher we just
wanted to finish the ride and about a
mile and a half from the house he gets a
flat yeah the flat was kind of a bummer
but you know it happens I was talking to
John he he stopped outside of the road
with me you know they're there are
certainly worse situations in which I
could have flatted we were next to a
vineyard so it's a beautiful day i
really ask for more so so he has to
actually get picked up in the follow car
and i managed it to make it home I just
wanted to finish the ride made it that
far
today's ride was was pretty good enjoyed
ourselves did some some wine country
touring it's a beautiful day it's
beautiful scenery great roads good right
take a wrong turn at Occidental